well
[Music]
the restaurant el shanghai taste
reopened its doors after a
shooting that left a waiter seriously
injured hello how are you health andrés
gonzález with an informative hat from iu
news nao in Spanish the owner of the
restaurant plans to donate all the money
raised up to  end of the year to help
his employee hospitalized after being
shot 11 times it is believed that chen jian one will
survive after this attack the
asian chamber of commerce also created an
andy golf account to help him all
the details on youtube.com the
spanish section
more companies  They are receiving not be
part of consumer electronics anymore or better
known as if Amazon is next year,
for example, they are among
the long list of companies that
withdraw from the event saying that it is for
safety and health protection,
experts say that this could have an impact
to our economy for a while the
convention asks all
attendees to be fully
v  cradled and wearing their
pons masks is preparing to open its
doors in the spring the new
owners want to bring back some
familiar faces for this reason they plan to
rehire at least 600 employees
who were laid off as soon as
the pandemic began for the moment not  there is an
opening date available
now we will look at the weather forecast
we will have some breezes
throughout the day with a chance of
showers in the afternoon and at night the
temperatures will be in the low
sixties and the possibility of showers
extends until christmas eve and
Possibly on Christmas morning, a
beautiful day, Andrés
González greets you with the
outraged newscast in Spanish
[Music]